ملعب أجنبي ومن المؤسف أن الدولة
ستهدمه وترسله للتبرع ، لكنني أعتقد أنه من أجل
قضية جيدة ، نعم بالتأكيد من
الجيد إعادة تدويره وإرساله
إلى دولة أخرى لاستخدامه من أجل
سبب وجيه
بالطبع أن الملعب يشغل مساحة
وعليك أن
تبنيها وأمها مكلف للغاية وبمجرد أن تقوم ببنائها
عليك الاستمرار في استخدامها للاستفادة من
الاستثمار الذي تم القيام به ، لذلك بالطبع أه
الملعب ليس شيئًا سيتم استخدامه
طوال الوقت لا تجري أحداثًا
باستخدام الاستاد ، لذا أعتقد أنه من
الجيد اختبار المشاركة مع
الدول الأخرى للاستفادة من كل هذه
الاستثمارات
الأجنبية ،
هذه فكرة جيدة جدًا لأن قطر
بها العديد من الملاعب وهذا الملعب
مبني فقط  لهذا الغرض من أجل
كأس العالم وربما يبقون ، لا
يحتاجون إلى الملعب ، سوف يتبرعون بهذه
الحاويات حاويات الاستاد اليوم
في العديد من البلدان الأخرى الذين يرغبون في استخدام
هذا في أي عمل آخر ، هذا أمر رائع للغاية.
د فكرة عنهم
أجنبية
[تصفيق].